hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about low potassium why because
potassium is probably the number one
deficiency with most people but it's the
hardest to detect because when you take
a blood test
most of the potassium 98% of your
potassium is inside the cell not outside
itself so when they do a blood test it's
not going to show up unless it's really
really really extreme so the type of
test that you would have to do would be
an intracellular test it's very
sophisticated people don't really ask
for it doctors probably don't even know
about it but there is a test that you
can do but I like to go by symptoms here
are some of the symptoms of low
potassium by the way this is not vitamin
K but this is a chemical symbol of
potassium as their k+ so when you're low
potassium the blood pressure will
increase why because potassium is a
physiological relaxer it's a
tranquilizer calm things down muscle
cramps because potassium is an
electrolyte sugar cravings why because
potassium helps you store sugar and it
will actually help you get rid of sugar
cravings because the storage of glucose
needs potassium okay constipation yeah
so that's another symptom of the low
potassium and then high insulin so
there's a relationship between sugar
blood sugars diabetes and potassium in
fact when you have enough potassium the
need for insulin goes down so I always
recommend potassium for diabetic clients
remember this is another one muscle
weakness you could have this
unexplainable muscle weakness and not
know why why because the the
electrolytes are needed to help the
muscles contract and that's why you have
an abnormal heartbeat because the heart
is a muscle same thing with this muscle
same thing with that muscle so these
abnormal heartbeats for example like at
atrial fibrillation arrhythmias that's a
combination of deficiency of potassium
and/or magnesium
okay anxiety and sleeping problems
because
- aciem is something to calm you down so
if you're doing something that doesn't
involve a lot of like some diet that
doesn't involve in a potassium you can
start manifesting a lot of these
symptoms now let's just go into what
causes low potassium well if you are
sick and you vomit or let's say you're a
bulimic that can cause that or maybe
you're just not eating enough in your
diet now you might say well I eat
bananas right well bananas only have 300
milligrams you need 4700 milligrams per
day to hit your your regular amount that
you need so you would have to consume I
don't know 12 bananas love bananas so we
don't want all that sugar so what we
want to do is we want to consume our
potassium from vegetables from salad and
you're going to need about 7 to 10 cups
okay if you watch my other videos I
talked about that it's not that hard you
just have a couple big salads if you
don't like salad take kale maybe a
little bit of berry blend it with water
and drink your salad ok that'll get the
potassium in there so we want to start
to increase that and that's how we
increase them from the diet you're going
to feel a lot better too because if
you're doing like a Atkins diet
high-protein unit you're going to
definitely need potassium you're going
to start feeling weakness because you
don't have an epitaphium
okay so ketosis is the state of
fat-burning when you're eating more fat
no carbs and you could become deficient
in potassium from that too so that's why
I always modify the ketosis diet and I
make sure that we have enough greens and
vegetables to help balance that and also
potassium is necessary for the digestion
in breakdown and build-up of protein so
people that are losing their hair for
example and they're eating just protein
thinking that they're going to get their
hair back without potassium sorry
doesn't work so we got diuretics so
you're on a blood pressure medication
well you're going to deplete your
hassium and keep the blood pressure
there interesting that's the diuretic so
that's one of side effects so you better
make sure that your diuretic is not
pulling out potassium and you're not
putting it back in okay high cortisol
that's stress stress can also deplete
potassium in fact I've had people do
advanced testing on their potassium
levels and they are eating a tremendous
amount of potassium but because they're
under a tremendous amount of stress
their potassium stays low because with
the adrenal it's almost like you have a
hole in the bucket and the potassium
goes right through so again when you're
under stress you need even more
potassium so anyway this potassium is
really important
I'm not when it's also high insulin will
cause a low potassium and that's sugar
so let's just add that to the list
consuming sugar will deplete your
potassium and you can even feel it in
your heartbeat just go it starts to go
boom-boom boom-boom fast you a strong
heartbeat you can hear it in your inner
ear that is a sign of low potassium
because you just ate a lot of sugar and
you need to start consuming more salad
to put that back so last one is drinking
too much water so this goes against what
everyone says that you have to drink
when you're you know you by the time you
drink it's too late because you're you
don't know when you're thirsty and
that's just the myth when you drink too
much water you create a condition called
hyponatremia which is a dilution of all
your electrolytes and then your heart
starts get going out of balance and you
can have a heart attack by drinking too
much water so you want to drink when
you're thirsty so you don't flush out
all your electrolytes because you're
drinking water but you're peeing on
electrolytes you're not putting in
electrolytes I like to hydrate my water
with lemon a little bit of apple cider
vinegar
maybe a little stevia if it's carbonated
I drink Pellegrino a lot or I drink
filtered water so I just want to kind of
give you an overall on this very common
deficiency that people have in the
symptoms so you can start thinking with
it and if you
you start having enemies then you know
it could be connected with that and then
you know the cause of that okay so I
hope that helped I will see you in the
next video